meteorologist Eric Fisher of our CBS
station WBZ is here again to break down
irma by the numbers Eric good morning
good morning Gail the storm not as
intense as what we saw yesterday but it
has a much larger wind field so that
will affect a broad area of the
southeast it's not just the storm but
it's a big area high pressure across the
Northeast that change in pressure
producing winds 450 miles across a
tropical storm force and tropical storm
force is maybe not a major hurricane but
it's still enough to cause a lot of
issues bring down some trees cause a lot
more power outages we've seen about 6
million of those already so far so there
you see the storm rain bands coming in
across Georgia South Carolina want to
show you some of the stats and some of
the peak numbers from emmet has
certainly been a very destructive
hurricane for us strongest gusts in the
United States a hundred and forty two
miles per hour that was measured in
Naples right near the airport right at
landfall as we look toward yesterday
afternoon storm surge highest measured
so far Cudjoe key that was that first
landfall in the keys it's between Big
Pine and Key West 10 to 14 feet and
we're really just starting to get the
big picture of the damage down there in
the keys rain total we've seen over a
foot in spots of florida from central
florida up toward the jacksonville area
that seems to be the band of the
heaviest rainfall there has been some
freshwater flooding with that so far so
some impressive numbers on the board so
far with Irma we've had a couple of very
destructive hurricanes back-to-back in
terms of any records here well it had
one hundred eighty five mile-per-hour
winds peak intensity member back when it
was toward the northern Leeward Islands
37 hours at 185 miles per hour satellite
record goes to 1966 but that's the
longest that we've ever measured it
forms east of 35 west what does that
mean well it's out by the Cape Verde
Islands that's really far out we haven't
had a hurricane actually strike the u.s.
that started that far out since 1893
hurricane three they didn't have names
back then and days since Harvey we had
landfall 16 days ago major hurricanes
within just over two weeks the last time
that we had a major hurricane before the
season was 2005 Charley so we went over
4,000 days than 16 how a verge is are
made Erick these are interesting
questions we've got some more though who
would you come over to the desk and sit
down with us and talk about sure no
problems at all
fire away as I walk on let me just begin
with this Jose is in the Atlantic when
do we expect it
what's its direction and when do we
expect to see it so it's in a bit of a
holding pattern right now it's waiting
for Irma to kind of unwind it's
dominating the flow over the eastern US
it's gonna drift between the Bahamas and
out toward Bermuda but in between the
two next five to six days it's gonna try
to move back in as we look toward next
weekend and early next week so we have a
ways to watch it and it's still to be
unclear exactly how those steering
currents gonna line up for a couple days
yet we need to calm down
then we get a clearer picture it's going
to come close to the coast and I think
North Carolina to New England would be
the spot to watch and and what about
this question that Nora asked in terms
of climate change in climate global
warming is it a factor a factor and what
we're seeing with these the number of
hurricanes
maybe not the number of hurricanes but
maybe the intensity of their actually
some theories out there and Oh Kerry
Emanuel at MIT saying that they might
see fewer hurricanes but the ones that
form maybe a little bit stronger the
reason for that is the ocean
temperatures now we've seen the water
temps one to two degrees above average
that can add an extra fuel to the fire
it doesn't cause hurricanes we're in the
peak of hurricane season we expect them
but it may make the top end a little bit
higher over time that we've had warm
water for years and no hurricanes so
it's not the only factor Kerry Emanuel
and MIT essentially saying we're gonna
see more Harvey type hurricanes where
there's heavy heavy rainfall right in a
warmer worlds we might see heavier
downpours scattered about maybe some
higher-end rain totals we saw those
unprecedented numbers in Texas with that
storm so certainly something that has
our attention and especially with surge
flooding we know that places as a fact
have higher water than 1960 when Donna
came ashore when you have surge it's
going to come up higher thanks for
inviting me over I appreciate / Eric
yeah thanks for having you on the face
information yeah anytime